okay now this is a work in progress
unless of course you like it yeah if you
like it can be the finished product yeah
we don't put together the best friggin
ads you've ever seen yeah else we'll die
trying
oh my friends dead no it's cool
being your dingdong self yes wow I
wouldn't drink that guy off with Freddy
Krueger's hand who was that a joke yeah
you've made an old lady very very
jaraguá Chrissy you're a bad person
go eat pineapples you Fathead shut up
all right now let's get down to brass
tacks who's his pants it's
Tim's jack shut up it's sell me this
pencil market Portage's it's a little
pocket for poor gauges and maybe the
baby
craps itself but I feel really good
about that one yeah it was like our best
fish in months man
really good to know
[Music]
gonna write it again when we're done
writing 102 hammers one more time it
will come back up even do a little time
it to left